hello my name is Phil Gallio and I'm
president of the George Washington
University Objectivist Club I'd like to
welcome you all here this evening and
thank you for coming to witness our
debate capitalism versus socialism which
is a moral system before I introduce our
four participants in tonight's debate
I'd like to let everyone know that the
George Washington University Objectivist
Club and the program board are the proud
sponsors of this event the Objectivist
Club is an on-campus student
organization whose goal is to provide
the opportunity for all students to
become acquainted with ideas which are
pro reason pro reality and pro
individual rights members will be able
will be available at the table in the
foyer during the break and for a brief
period after the debate to provide
information about objectivism and the
club our next meeting is November 20th a
week from this Thursday next door at the
Marvin Center dr. ed Locke professor at
the University of Maryland will conduct
a question and answer period on
objectivism entitled why does man need a
philosophy why objectivism the public is
invited to attend this free meeting for
all those who are interested there will
be a reception for tonight's
participants immediately following the
debate that should give you the
opportunity to speak with our four
guests on a more personal level it will
be held next door in the Marvin Center
room 501 now without further delay I'd
like to introduce tonight's participants
for safor debaters on your left arguing
for the socialist position will be
Christopher Hitchens and John Judas
mr. Hitchens receives his graduate
degree in philosophy politics and
economics from Balliol College in Oxford
England he currently writes a column
called the Minority Report for the
Nation magazine he is also the current
American columnist for the New Statesman
the primary publication of the
social-democratic political left in
London England mr. Hitchens has edited
and written several books including his
recently published Cyprus he frequently
debates conservatives on radio
television and campus forums and has
appeared on William Bach
television program firing line mr. Judas
received his MA in philosophy from the
University of California at Berkeley he
is a founding editor of the socialist
review and is currently senior editor of
in these times he is on the editorial
board of the progressive and writes
political articles for the New Republic
mr. Judas has just completed a biography
of William F Buckley which will be
published by Simon & Schuster in about a
year on your right
advocating the capitalist position will
be Harry Binswanger and John Ridpath
dr. Binswanger received his PhD from
Columbia University he taught philosophy
for many years at Hunter College in New
York City in 1979 he left the academic
world to launch the Objectivist forum a
magazine devoted to Iran's philosophy
and its application to cultural issues
dr. Binswanger dr. Binswanger is just
published book the Iran lexicon is a
philosophical dictionary of Objectivism
dr. Binswanger has written and lectured
extensively in support of the philosophy
of Objectivism
dr. Ridpath received his master's degree
in business administration from the
University of Toronto and as a PhD in
economics from the University of
Virginia he is currently an associate
professor of economics and social
science at York University in Toronto
where he has been a recipient of the
prestigious award given by the Ontario
Council of university faculty
associations dr. Ridpath has been an
advisor to the National Foundation for
public policy development a canadian
think-tank and has spoken at the
national policy conferences sponsored by
the canadian Progressive Conservative
Party
Professor Steven Keller director of
debate here at the George Washington
University has graciously agreed to
moderate tonight's intellectual combat
professor Keller is with the Department
of Communications and theatre and
teaches a variety of public address
courses here at GW I'm sure you all join
me in thanking tonight's participants
for taking the time to present their
views on this important question and
professor Keller for his assistance in
planning and executing this
confrontation and the GW program board
for its sponsorship
under debate this evening will be the
morality of each posing system socialism
versus capitalism the participants are
expected to defend each system by
presenting the underlying ethical
principles upon which it rests they have
been selected because they represent
extreme polar opposite positions I'm
stressing that the issue here is
morality not economics alone we are here
to debate the fundamental moral
alternatives to focus on the essential
conflict between two absolutely opposed
systems socialism and laissez-faire
capitalism thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
my guess is as the evening progresses
there will be very little question in
your mind as to who is seated on the
left and who is seated on the right the
intellectual enlightenment that will be
served to us this evening will probably
be very freewheeling at the same time it
will have a time and a structure to it
the participants have agreed to the
following speech sequence and time
lengths each speaker alternating back
and forth between sides will make an 8
minute opening statement these opening
statements will then be followed by each
speaker making a 5 minute reply after
the opening statements and the reply we
very much encourage your participation
there will be a microphone set up at
which you'll are welcome to ask
questions of the participants those
questions can be directed to a
particular participant or merely to a
side following the questioning period
there will be a four minute per side
closing statement those four minutes can
be divided among the participants on
that side however they choose starting
us off this evening will be mr. Harry
Vince winger mr. Vince winger
[Applause]
thank you the opposition between
capitalism and socialism is a moral
opposition each side must state and
defend the moral basis of its political
views we champion capitalism as the only
moral political system what is morality
morality is a code of values to guide
man's choices there is only one
fundamental choice to live or not to be
or not to be if one chooses to live then
one must act in a certain way one must
achieve certain goals certain values one
must satisfy one's needs if one does not
choose to live then no action and no
values are possible or necessary one
simply sits and waits to die life in
other words is the ultimate goal at the
root of all values life is a self
justifying primary this is why you need
a morality you need a moral code in
order to know how to live and that means
that the standard of morality the
abstract principle by which we judge
good and evil is man's life every
species has a specific means of survival
set by its nature this is a simple
biological fact
unlike the lower animals man has the
power of choice but he doesn't have a
choice over his basic nature and his
basic needs what is man's means of
survival how does man get his food his
shelter is safety his health and so
forth well obviously not by any great
strength of muscle or by claw or Fang
not by instinct but by thinking by
reason reason the conceptual Faculty is
man's basic means of survival now this
is a key to our whole position so I want
to stress this reason thinking the use
of man's intelligence is his means of
survival man survives not by
appropriating pre-existing values the
way that
animals do but by creating new values
the means of doing this is productive
work and by production I mean the
application of reason to reshaping
matter to serve human ends it is not
true in other words that wealth exists
in some static quantity like a natural
resource so that when one person gets
more another automatically gets less
life is not a zero-sum game wealth is
created it isn't found and the creation
of wealth takes knowledge knowledge is
available only through rational thinking
thus reason is man's only means of
knowledge and therefore his basic means
of survival look around us right now
we're in a man-made world or in a
man-made environment electric lights
plastic seats clothes from artificial
and natural fibers from all parts of the
world a microphone system where did all
these things come from they came from
the minds of the scientists who
discovered the physical laws involved
from the engineers who found out how to
translate that abstract knowledge into
working instruments from the
entrepreneurs who risk their capital to
bring these things to a market to serve
human need and in addition the physical
labor under the direction of the
intelligence of the entrepreneur to
produce them the moving cause here the
basic source of all these things is not
then the physical labor as such it's not
muscle power it is not that we expend
more calories of energy per minute than
the caveman and that's why we are here
in an auditorium lit by electricity and
he is in the cave in fact we put forth
much less muscular labor today than in
any time in human history we even go out
of their way to create exercise because
we find ourselves doing so little in our
work the actual source of wealth then is
man's mind man's rational thinking
capacity now it is true that some men
can
attempt to live without using their
minds but they can do so only by
parasitizing the wealth created by those
who did choose to think and work it is
still true that man's life depends upon
thinking even though some people mooch
or steal the products of the thinking of
others those others had to think now a
morality who standard is man's life then
man's life as a rational productive
being cannot permit such parata's
parasitism a rational morality such as
we are advocating does not advocate the
master/slave relationship or the robber
victim relationship but independence men
must deal with each other as independent
equals each man being an end in himself
not the means to the ends of others each
man must stand on his own achieve his
own values live his own life earn his
own happiness he does get it of course a
value from the association with others
he's not a hermit but let's there be no
mistake about what we're advocating we
are advocating selfishness rational
egoistic selfishness as the proper code
for men to deal with each other
the reason is that selfishness is
required by life as such the opposite of
selfishness which means the achievement
of your own values is a surrender of
your values the sacrifice of a higher
value to a lower value or the sacrifice
of a value to a zero to nothing now that
is obviously the antithesis of life life
is a process of value achievement full
surrender of all values would mean death
anytime you eat a mouthful of food for
yourself rather than giving it to some
starving Indian beggar are you doing
that on the principle not of altruism or
self-sacrifice but of egoism now I want
to be clear rational selfishness does
not mean sacrificing others to yourself
that would be inconsistent each man must
be selfish
each man must live his own life and men
must trade value for value when they do
to each other so we hold that man is
born free not only politically but
morally you are not born in debt to
others you have no duties to others you
have you are not obligated to seek their
happiness you are the owner of your own
life your life is not the means to any
higher end it is the ultimate end as I
said it's your basic choice to live or
not man is not a sacrificial animal now
in particular we emphatically reject the
idea that need is a claim you know the
slogan in the advertisement from each
according to his ability to each
according to his needs we reject that
because it's incompatible with human
survival a morality that sacrifices
ability to need is a morality that holds
suffering lack disease impotence failure
as that which entitles one to receive
values the needs that must be considered
are the needs of the producers if you
want to use that language what social
conditions are required for man to
produce wealth well since the production
of wealth I argued is through reason
there is only one basic thing required
you must respect man's sovereign reason
this means one must oppose the use of
physical force one must deal with other
men by persuasion not by force so a
basic principle of capitalism is all
interactions must be voluntary because
the forest is the anti mind and the anti
mind is the anti life thank you
thank you very much mr. Vince winger
mr. Judas will join the debate I was
happy to learn that we would be having a
debate between socialism and lace a fair
capitalism because I'm uncomfortable
debating capitalism rather than lace a
fair capitalism since I stand for a
fleeting not ideal myself I prefer to
have to a contend with another fleeting
ideal I should warn you that my views as
a socialist
are not necessarily representative all
socialists in one sense I'm a radical in
another sense I'm a conservative
I'm radical I suppose in the sense that
I don't think that the now what is it
now that the German Democratic Republic
the East Germany is either democratic or
socialist and I'm conservative in the
sense that I think that socialism itself
will evolve out of capitalism and share
many of the features of modern
democratic capitalism not only the
parliamentary system and civil liberties
but also the rudiments of the market and
small and medium scale private property
as well now what is the moral basis of
socialism as I describe it well I'm
gonna say something that might seem
paradoxical here and that is that the
moral basis of socialism is really no
different than that of lace a fair
capitalism socialism comes out of the
failure of lace affair capitalism to
realize its own ideals those ideals are
basically three one which Harry
binswanger discussed is an ideal of a
man himself of human beings themselves
having a higher capability and a and of
society itself being structured in such
a way is to fulfill that higher
capability it's an ideal that comes from
the Greeks goes through Hegel the
Enlightenment thinkers the other ideals
are those of liberty and equality and
those were born out of the
struggle to wrest capitalism out of
feudalism Liberty as as the right to be
free of inherited obligation to be born
not on a manner in which one one's life
was laid before him but to have a
possibility of doing different things
with one's life equality again as being
born neither in a particular caste or
class a rough equality but an equality
based on the absence of an aristocracy
now these three ideals of what one might
call self creativity equality and
Liberty were the ideals that inform
Jefferson Jackson Lincoln what we might
call the democratic tradition and
American thought and the way that they
conceived them being fulfilled was in
terms of society of equal small
producers in which each person or family
would be roughly equal would be free and
would have the power to control their
own destiny in society unfortunately
these dreams were not realized instead
of a society of small producers we had a
society of large producers a society of
classes of society in which poverty
existed alongside great wealth in other
words the society that we know as modern
capitalism today and socialism as an
idea of the 19th century was born
precisely out of the understanding that
that society of lazy fair capitalism
could never be and that in order to
realize that you have to have a somewhat
different kind of society one in which
human beings themselves owned the means
of production in which there were no
classes now here's the difficult part
because as I said at the beginning I'm a
radical in the sense that I don't think
that that what we have today in the name
of socialism is socialism and I think
we'll get to talk about that a little
more in the debate but but let me just
briefly explain what I'm talking about
marks in the early socialists always
assumed that socialism would arise only
in highly industrialized societies with
a democratic tradition highly
industrialized because only in those
societies would people have the time
with the productivity exists in other
words where people would have the time
to rule themselves democratic because
only in those societies would people be
educated both in trade unions and
Parliament to rule themselves but
socialist movements first took power not
in highly industrialized societies but
in a semi industrialized nation with a
very scant democratic tradition the
Soviet Union Russia and socialism itself
as it evolved came to be not so much a
specific social system after the name of
Marx but rather a means of vindicating
or legitimizing a movement that stood
for something quite different for
socialism most of the societies that
call themselves socialism are no more
socialist than most of the right-wing
movements that call themselves
democratic I'm sure you know there are
those now the question is is socialism
itself as I'm describing it possible is
it possible to fulfill this dream of
liberty equality and self creativity
there's a problem not only with existing
socialist societies and the pawl that
they have cast over our notion of what
it is to be socialist but there's a
problem in fact with Marx himself and
the socialists of the 19th century in my
opinion there's a fundamental error in
Marx's thought and that is what Marx
understood and the heart of what's
valuable of marx is that's that one
society evolves out of the other it both
absorbs part of another society and it
negates part of another society that's
going to be true of the of an economy of
a socialist society that is we cannot
conceive of a what Marx conceived of as
a socialist economy was simply the
negation of a cap
the economy in which no markets existed
and in which economic power would be
concentrated in the collectivity what
happened as a result of that is that the
collectivity became the state the state
itself was became ruled by a political
elite and as Hikind von Mises and
various other thinkers warned one laid
the basis on behalf of Marxism one laid
the basis for a totalitarianism so what
I'm describing as Marxism would have to
be in fact a mix of lace a fair
capitalism and Marxism
what what is called in the world today
marked market socialism but market
socialism founded upon democracy thank
you the debate this evening is in
essence about two issues the first issue
is why the initiation of physical force
is immoral and the second issue is which
social system employs the initiation of
physical force in which social system
rejects it
professor benswanger has addressed
himself to the question of what are the
standards of moral value that we employ
and arguing for capitalism I'm going to
apply what he has said to the question
of capitalism as a social system I'd
like to start by observing that a
society is nothing more than a
collection of individuals who are
interrelating with each other according
to rules laws customs which pertain in
that culture if one asked what is it the
basis of these rules and these laws one
would discover that at the basis of
these things lies certain philosophical
principles such as we have been
discussing principles with regards to
nature of reality the nature of man what
man social needs are that is why
philosophical principles are at the
heart of a social system as
social system capitalism socialism
whatever you like the essence of these
social systems is philosophical
principles which underlie them the
fundamental identifying characteristic
of any social system is the set of moral
and philosophical principles which it
embodies and this debate really is about
the differing principles underlying
socialism and capitalism
now before discussing capitalism as a
social system
I want to remark on the state on
government as the central social
institution it is the enforcer of the
laws of the principles which are in
place in the culture it is the central
social institution it is the if you like
dominating social institution in a
culture if we would ask ourself what is
the government what is the state as a
social institution what is its essential
fight defining characteristic we would
see that the central essential defining
characteristic of government is that it
is that social institution that has a
legal monopoly over the use of force in
society that is what government is a
central question with regards to any
social system therefore is what are the
principles dictating the way that the
state relates to its individual citizens
now what would a moral social system be
a moral social system would be one which
was based on pro-life principles one
which was based on the values that human
life requires one that serves man's life
rather than destroys man's life one in
which the government is limited in its
functions to the social requirements of
human life in other words the moral
social system would be one which
acknowledged and protected man's
fundamental social need which is for
freedom from the initiation of physical
force in a social context now it is the
concept of man's rights which
captures man's need to be left free from
the initiation of physical force on the
part of his neighbors when he deals with
them in society it is man's right to
life liberty private property in the
pursuit of happiness which morally
sanctions his need for freedom the
individual is a sovereign entity his
life belongs to him it does not belong
to anybody else and it is immoral of
anybody else or any social institution
to attack him to violate his rights and
force him to live for the needs of
others man needs freedom to act he
cannot be physically barred from acting
once he has decided through the
irrational use of his mind on the goals
he wishes to pursue and if he should
succeed in his actions in gaining values
he needs the right to own those values
and to retain them for his own use
he needs the right to private property
without property rights no human life is
possible the principle of man's rights
is the bridge from morality to the
question of the moral social system
the only moral social system therefore
is the system which is based on the
recognition of man's rights on the
recognition of man's need to be free
from physical force the only moral
social system is that social system
where the government is limited to this
function where it never initiates force
in order to violate the rights of its
own citizens where it supplies the
police the Armed Forces and the courts
for dealing with rights violations and
in which it has no economic functions
whatsoever just as state should be
separated from church state should also
be properly totally separated from
economics now the proper definition of
capitalism as a social system is to
identify the fundamental principle
underlying capitalism the fundamental
moral principle underlying capitalism is
the sovereign individual and his right
to his own life and his own property
therefore the proper definition of
capitalism is it is the social system
based on the uncompromising recognition
and protection of individuals rights
this is a definition in terms of
fundamentals now the Socialists define
capitalism
as a social system where there is wage
labor and where there is private
property in the means of production
these are derivatives it is true that
there is private property in the means
of production it is true that there is
wage markets the market for wage labour
but these are expressions of every
individual's right to act on his own in
his own interests and trade accordingly
and voluntarily with his fellow man so
to identify capitalism as a social
system exhibiting wage labor and private
ownership of the means of production is
superficial the fundamental and proper
definition of capitalism is that it
protects every man's right to his own
life now the implications of properly
defining capitalism are first of all
that there is in a true capitalist
society no connection between economics
and politics economic power which is
earned by producers by virtue of their
ability to produce values which other
people will buy is a positive it is a
benefit to everybody to have a present
in our society people who are capable of
earning economic power political power
in the other hand is based on the power
of a gun on the power of the government
to actually violate men's rights coerce
them expropriate their property and it
is a negative and there is no connection
in a capitalist social system if it's
properly understood between business and
government secondly there is no ad
vacations in capitalism of the right to
goods per se people only have the right
to act freely they do not have the right
to the goods of others there is no such
thing as a right to a job in other words
to force another person to give you a
job a right to an education in other
words to force another person to give
you an education or a right to any such
possessions at all now given this is
obvious that capitalism has never yet
fully existed in human history it lies
ahead rather than behind the 19th
century in Britain in the United States
or the closest approximation z' of it
and we see great productivity and
benevolence the moral is the practical
but today we have no examples of
capitalism in the world we only have
mixed systems which in fact our systems
of income
principles principles of statism such as
the socials put forward and some
vestiges of freedom now it is my view
that they haven't having completed our
comments that the we as a capitalists
have done what is required of us which
is to make a case for capitalism that is
our case for capitalism is the only
moral system system available to man
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
Thank You mr. Redpath mr. hitchens will
be making the final eight minute
statement Thank You professor I think
that the organizers of this meeting must
be congratulated on the Brio and also I
think on their timing we are met today
as witnesses of the decomposition of a
political regime in this capital city
which uses the language of capitalism
and a free enterprise employs the
ideology of selfishness and
self-interest and stresses the rhetoric
of less a fair while bloating and
expanding the road of the state
debauching the treasure in the currency
and relying upon a state within a state
for the secret conduct of Merson policy
there may and I think that will not be
any convergence of ideas between
socialist and capitalist schools this
evening but this need not prevent us I
think from seeing that a regime may
combine the basest features of statism
and collectivism with the basest
elements of utilitarianism and
libertarianism - and I think if we
recognize that we may have ground for
debate what is it I better get on with
it
to be a socialist necessary conditions
in my submission rather than sufficient
ones must include the following it is
necessary to hold firstly that all
divisions of class nation race and sex
are in the last resort and man-made and
can be man unmade are in no sense part
of a divine or natural ordinance and
that we are members like it or know of
one race the human race that
civilization is in fact second a
cooperative enterprise whether the
cooperation is coerced as it was in most
of recorded history or voluntary as has
been occasionally found and can still be
found in our century but that it is a
cooperative enterprise cannot be denied
there is no other means that's to say of
civilization that the third that the
limits of creative in
are set by the limits of nature and the
very few human actions can therefore be
said in the last instance to be entirely
private the earth is in point of fact a
common Treasury as the English Levellers
used to say in the Puritan revolution
hoping that it was so it is in fact the
case and again whether we like it or not
whether we care to treat it as such or
not for that there is no God and no
supernatural that this recognition
obliges obliges us morally to maximize
the felicity of the one life that we are
permitted and fifth that the principle
of from each according to his ability or
her ability and to each according to his
or her need is an easily realizable one
prefigured already in human society by
the working principles of the bourgeois
family that unique engine of thrift
enterprise the transmission of morality
operates precisely on the principle of
from each according to his or her
ability and to each according to his or
her need there is in fact no other way
that a family could decently all
possibly be run I make no moral judgment
as between the decency and the
possibility such a such a distinction
would be OTAs marxists described freedom
as the recognition of necessity and only
then proceeded to say that the free
development of each is the condition for
the free development of all a
stipulation that obviously implies its
corollary that the educator must be
educated that's why I stress the above
as necessary conditions rather than
sufficient ones we do not ask for these
things to be true we might even prefer
them not to be but we must recognize
them as given and as such sufficient
conditions I think Center on the
question of class Marxists recognized
that history is indeed the contest of
competing social forces and that so is
the present such a competition all
attempts to describe society as merely
organic and harmonious or as a free
competition or race between individuals
with differing attainments and
endowments fail because they ignore this
simple and obvious fact which again we
do not preach we simply recognize insist
upon and make as a point of departure
let me if I may quote you from Marx and
Engel
preface to the German ideology in 1845
where they say that they and their
supporters and I'm quoting now we do not
preach morality at all they do not put
to people a moral demand love one
another do not be eager to set cetera on
the contrary they are very well aware
that egoism just as much as selflessness
is indefinite circumstances a necessary
form of the self assertion of
individuals I think this shows clearly
enough that Marxists understand what
Randy ins term as if they discovered it
the virtue of selfishness but as marks
and angles also wrote in the same period
in their holy family they saw the need
for selfishness to be transcended I'm
quoting again directly from the Holy
Family 1845 also if enlightened
self-interest is the principle of all
morality man's private interest must be
made to coincide with the interest of
humanity if man is shaped by environment
his environment must be made human it is
on this apparent paradox that we take
our stand and against the neo-kantian x'
the early Marxist argued that morality
could not be derived from abstract first
principles of read or write but had to
correspond to the real conditions of
society nowadays I think this argument
seems quaint in in its intensity and
fervor because evolution itself and
specifically the evolution of modern
capitalism into a new symbiosis with the
state has borne in upon the dullest line
the recognition that if humanity does
not yet think in terms of a common
destiny it has at least had to think in
terms of a common fate to put it at its
most vulgar materialist level we are all
collectivized by the same ozone layer
the thermonuclear world is a great
leveler and just as there can be no
purely moral conscientious objection in
a thermonuclear conflict nor can there
be any merely ethical or self-interested
collaboration with it everybody after
all in this auditorium is a uniformed
conscript you cannot conscientiously
object to the nuclear conscription that
has made of each of you our soldiers and
put you in the frontline while the real
soldiers are in the bunker
this-this-this is this recognition of
reality enforces a sense of of
collective humanity upon us again we do
not preach this we recognize it
socialism said Oscar Wilde would free us
from the distressing necessity of living
for others the feelings of compassion
and solidarity and responsibility after
all are no less instinct in our species
than those of self-interest it's
precisely because these instincts of
solidarity and compassion represent a
human need a need to be of help to
others point very well made by Professor
Richard Kipnis in his famous book the
gift relationship because they are a
need there is no need to make the
sentimental presumption of altruism or
to wrestle with the tautology that
altruism represents Marx and Engels I'll
close on this in the preface to their
1848 manifesto made capitalism a series
of almost lirikl compliments and in fact
few proponents of the capitalist system
have ever summarized its virtues those
of creativity innovation the bursting of
feudal and antique tribal fetters as
well as Marx did but Marx and Engels
also saw what since become obvious the
capitalism is not the last word that in
freeing mankind from ancient obligations
it made him a prisoner of market forces
which also develop their own mythology
and ideology their own mystification and
their own bondage like the comrade Judas
I also believe that capitalism is the
harbinger of socialism that it's
necessary not merely to contest or
negate its ethical claims but to
transcend them to build upon them and
from this if I may coin a phrase
dialectic I think we might get a truly
human and an illusion morality that was
free from superstition or religion on
that realizable aspiration I rest my
case
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
Thank You mr. Hitchens the next four
rejoinders will be five minutes in
length and they will follow the same
sequence of the first floor it will be
after these speeches that the audience
will begin its questioning period
I'm a little bit at a loss since both of
my opponents or our opponents seemed to
be presenting themselves as the
Republicans used to to the Democrats me
too we're for freedom to wear for some
form of lazy fair integrated with
socialism we are for liberty and we both
share a dislike of Ronald Reagan well we
all four agree on that one point that
Ronald Reagan is a disgrace probably for
different reasons probably for different
reasons I didn't vote for him either in
either election because I thought he was
a phony and I agree with mr. Hitchens
that he preaches the rhetoric of lazy
fair or at least of half fair capitalism
but then his actions seem to be dictated
by the New York Times so I view him as
Reagan Carter in Reagan's clothing in
effect that's for concrete application
but there seems to be so much rushing to
agree with us that I wonder are we doing
better than I thought
people used to be absolutely knocked off
their chairs by someone advocating
laissez faire and maybe we've become a
little bit too successful so let's bring
this down from the clouds a little bit
we advocate the immediate abolition of
the antitrust laws
we advocate the immediate removal of the
welfare system as fast as as possible
perhaps over four or five years to the
total elimination of all welfare we
advocate the immediate abolition of the
Federal Trade Commission the Securities
and Exchange Commission the federal
depository insurance company
the CCC ICC just about any alphabet
agency you can
bring up when we're talking about
something very different from socialism
we're talking about untrammeled complete
free trade where people can buy and sell
as they choose as long as they do not
initiate physical force against others
now I wanted to just respond to a few
implications of ideas in the socialist
side that I want to disavow we do not
hold equality as a value or virtue or
ideal if by equality you mean anything
other than equal rights before the law
that term is used very ambiguously equal
rights before the law so that there is
one system of justice in the law courts
for rich and for poor is exactly what
I've been arguing for today all the
rights are on the side of the poor and
the workers and all the suffering is on
the side of those big capitalists
businessmen they are considered guilty
in any confrontation without the need
for proof or evidence they're considered
guilty because they're greedy
capitalists so equality before the law
yes but equality of income equality of
life equality in any other sense
absolutely no people have different
abilities people work with different
degrees of intensity and effort and
success and to some extent just plain
luck and those qualities have no moral
significance are those inequalities have
no moral significance whatsoever I have
never in all my years and philosophy
come across any argument as to why there
is any moral issue involved in one man
having a thousand times the wealth of
his neighbor I would like to know on
what basis is there something wrong with
that and on what basis is it better if
the incomes or Wealth's are equalized
because there is no such argument as to
the family being altruistic I don't
belong to a family we are not Reagan
conservatives we do not stand up here in
champion family we champion the
individual I would like to find someone
I can marry I don't plan to have
children and if I have someone that I
love whom I marry it won't be
someone who joins with me on the basis
of from each according to his ability to
each according to his needs it will be a
trading value for value both
economically and in terms of spiritual
values finally the idea of class and
collectivism we totally disavow there is
no such thing as a class there are just
individuals and I would claim if I had
time that that's based on the denial of
free will their view is based on
determinism the idea that if you're born
in such and such a situation you have to
have the ideas and values of your
parents we uphold free will that a man
makes himself thank you
[Applause]
well I wonder whether you found it as
difficult to understand Christopher and
I as I sometimes found find it difficult
to understand the Objectivists I think
that we both have to a certain extent a
metaphysics that we understand and that
may not be comprehensible to people
outside at least I found I found myself
at a loss at times trying to understand
the meaning of such words as life and
selfishness as I listen to my fellow
debaters discuss capitalism let me try
to restate if I will some of my argument
and while I do that I'll refer to what
points that have been made
first I I see capitalism as a social
system as a historical system not as an
ideal that has not yet been realized as
a social system that he that evolved out
of feudalism and that has a certain
history and it's a history that we can
learn from in in the United States the
the crucial part of that history is the
one that really is at stake here it's
the history of the early republic
because in those days were born the
ideals by which we still live by which
were governed as Christopher mentioned
hypocritically so that so that the
crucial question for us is how can those
lace a fair ideals be realized and what
happened in America what happened during
the Civil War why was it that we fought
a war based on the idea of all men are
created equal and out of that let's say
60 years later we had a society in which
there was gross inequality now are there
classes our people do people have free
will
I think here that there's a confusion of
normative and description
and in descriptive terms whether we're
talking about how life ought to be
and/or how life is whether in fact the
society is organized a certain way and
whether it ought to be organized a
certain way and what I'm trying to say
is that out of this attempt in our
Jeffersonian Jacksonian period the
period of the civil war to create a
society that was free and equal much
different society got created one in
which there were great not only
differences in income but differences in
income that were related to differences
in the relationship that people had to
private property and particularly to
large-scale private property and that's
what we talk about when we talk about
classes and that helps us understand
certain things about the society now the
state our governments necessary
something that that again was an issue
for Tom Paine and is an issue for us
today there are certain there are
certain reasons I think why we have to
have a government today and why it does
have to play a certain role in the
economy and I don't mean just antitrust
laws I mean the experience of the great
depression of depressions that that that
began in the early 19th century panics
leading up through the depression of the
1890s the depression of the 1930s
depressions which were caused by the
anarchy of the capitalist system the
only solution for which was some form of
government regulation whether we like it
or not and today I would suggest that
that in many to a great extent our own
problems as an economy our declining
balance of trade if I can use such a
mundane and dirty expression you know no
time when we're talking about much more
high-level thing is partly related to
the fact that that our economy is
structured so differently than the
Japanese and that we haven't
sufficiently used our government in a
creative economic way to increase our
own productivity but rather under the
name of lace a fair have only used it to
to protect certain forms of greed and
largesse so I hope we're not speaking
entirely past each other and that we can
have this a fruitful discussion of what
is at stake in this issue between
capitalism and socialism
[Applause]
[Music]
mmm
well these I've debated socialism missus
my tenth time these are definitely the
nicest socialists I ever debated however
I think I'll take off the gloves a
little bit here because in fact there is
fundamental difference on the stage and
I want to make it explicit what it is
before I do that I would like to say
that the socialists been putting forward
the values that they say socialism
embraces I don't really think they have
made an argument for those values it's
one thing to state your values it's
another thing to try and show why those
values serve man's life and I really
don't believe that they did that I
thought that the idea of Liberty that
they put forward which meant that we
were to be born free of inherited duties
and obligations as a very small
component of what it really means to a
man to be free so that I really am not
convinced that the Socialists have got
into the ethics of the case for
socialism let alone the view of man that
might underlie the ethics that they
would have had to have argued for the
principle to each from each according to
his ability to each according to his
need is really an endorsement of the
morality of altruism the morality that
some people to live the virtuous life
should voluntarily give up some of their
wealth so that others who have less can
benefit it is morality of self-sacrifice
and they should argue for that morality
that is the morality that socialism
attempts to institutionalize in society
they have not acknowledged the role of
force in a socialist culture they have
said a few things which hint on that
professor Hitchens for example
I guess it isn't professor is it
referred to civilization throughout
history was a matter of cooperation and
he said as an aside coerced or otherwise
it's a big difference he also quoted
Marx where he said that Marx had said
that private interest was alright but it
must be made to mesh with the general
interest now what does this mean this
means that the Socialists in fact are
advocates of what we can properly call a
statist society a society where the
state has a big function to play in
essence where the state is going to take
over by expropriation the private
property of the producers of a country
and run that private property according
to what they think is in the best
interests of everyone
socialism rests on an enormous act of
the expropriation of property which is a
violent act and so consequently the
Socialists have really not addressed the
questions to the role of the state in
their ideal society it is no accident
that every society in history whether
there has been yet achieved a perfect
social Society or not every attempt has
ended up of course with a very very
large role for the state to play which
is a denial of the rights of man and if
man's need for freedom in a social
context and is exactly the opposite of
what we are talking about it turns out
as mr. Judith said that we notice he
claims that the anarchy of capitalism
caused depressions which set up a stage
for the need for government well in fact
there is a very good debate which I
think is conclusive that in fact it was
not the market that caused depressions
was interference with the market that
caused depressions and it was early
statism which then turned and used the
depressions excuse for more statism but
the fact that matter is they are
advocates of statism they in essence say
you know it turns out that if we leave
people free there are unfortunately
problems which develop and so
consequently we have to bring the state
to bear in order to create the beautiful
world so the essence of what the
socialists are talking about
in my judgment is give me the power of
government give me the gun
because I want to build a beautiful
world according to my blueprint and I
have plans through which I will coerce
everybody who would not voluntarily
cooperate with these plans into living
into the in the beautiful future which
they apparently do not understand
now we're opposed to that we are
standing up for freedom in a serious way
we are standing up for the principles
this country was founded on we are
standing up with the principle of man's
inalienable rights and we are taking
them seriously and not willing to
compromise them that's all now I want to
conclude by saying that mr. Judas
started he said that he referred to
laissez-faire capitalism as a fleeting
ideal it is not a fleeting ideal despite
their claims that capitalism has already
existed it has not for the reasons I
presented but it can exist ideas
determine human history and that's what
this debate is about about ideas for the
future of this culture and hopefully if
the ideas we're putting forward
eventually hold sway in this culture we
will be half fortunate enough to see a
true less a fairer deal it will be not a
fleeting ideal by any means at all thank
you
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
Thank You mr. Redpath the last speaker
at this stage of the debate will be mr.
Hitchens following mr. Hitchens
presentation the audience questioning
will commence
mr. Hitchens I regret that what I say
will be a little more fragmentary than
my opening presentation because there
are a number of challenges that have
been offered to our side which I mustn't
let pass but could only deal with one at
a time first I specifically did not
state that the principle of from each
etc as I think we can agree to call it
as embodied in the voice of our family
was a principle of altruism it was
simply a principle of necessity there is
no other way that the family could be
run and that therefore this principle
prefigures the extension of such a
principle to the society itself and we
can see it as it were in the womb of the
oldest angles would have said and was in
fact over fond of saying now this
there's a very great and unrecognized I
think in their own minds confusion in
our two opponents here about capitalism
liberty and private property in the
relationship between them the history of
capitalism and even more so this should
be said of the history of capitalism in
its imperialist phase it's heroic period
is the history of expropriation it is
the history of the robbery of private
property for millions and millions of
people Marx observing this process in
the Communist Manifesto remarks on the
tremendous advances in productivity and
technique and innovation that were
thereby enabled but he does point to the
fact that many many people who hitherto
had owned land properties or were were
were expropriated collectivized and made
into the modern proletarian
he thought he thought the price was
worth paying he thought capitalism was
an advance over what had gone before but
let nobody tell you that capitalism
cannot coexist with the expropriation of
private property it can and does this I
think would be would assist us to answer
an even more intriguing question which
is why it is that capitalism has only
ever evolved successfully in a very few
countries I think this is very probably
because I have to be condensed here
because it's evolution
Benicio was based on the robbery of
other countries wealth and productivity
let me again remind you of what Marx
said about India
a tremendous expropriation by British
imperialism of of the resources of
capital accumulation from India an
enormous an enormous input to the
British industrial revolution still the
heartland of the evolution of capitalism
but a fantastic Desson of private
property in India again Marx thought it
was probably in the long run justifiable
because India would in the end succeed
in coming together as him as a state and
overcoming the feudal ties imposed by
the Mughal Emperors that had been
sundered by the imperialist invasion but
don't let anybody suggest you for
instant that capitalism does not regard
people as means probably more than any
other system in history it has made a
virtue of that ability of the ability to
conscripted spur create and to dis
possess in order to become an engine of
wealth and that is why finally the
responsibility for the overweening power
of certain states is that historically
speaking of capitalism because in the
countries where capitalism either did
not or because of imperialism could not
take root capital accumulation had to be
done another way you can't not have
capital after all though you can not
have capitalism and capital can be
accumulated one where can be accumulated
the other and in the oriental despotisms
of the of the east and the modern
versions of those capitalism had to be
substituted for by the state but that is
because of the failure of capitalism
which
intimately related to it let me say I
can't blame them for everything the sits
perfectly simplistic to say the
capitalism represents freedom from state
power because both in the countries of
its success and in the countries of its
failure the relationship with the modern
state the giant state the state that can
regard the citizen as its property for
large numbers of practical purposes is
very close indeed
and I think this what I have said should
be enough in itself to rebut the
ridiculous accusation that only
socialists are interested in violence I
could start all need it for the for the
vindication of their program I could
really could stand here all night and
read the list of names of people who've
been murdered by capitalist regimes when
the UN the interest of illicit private
property and governments based on it is
felt to be threatened there is no length
to which capital will not go in those
contingencies fascism was capitalism the
structure of the capitalist state in
Germany survived and coexisted to
survive and in Italy and in Spain
survived survived and coexisted with the
fascist period throughout I don't mean
to say that capitalism is fascism but
it's but capitalism can coexist with any
system and its attitude to Liberty is as
instrumental and contingent as its
attitude to equality I see I have no
more time but I'm prepared to defend
anything I've said a greater length in
the subsequent period thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
at this point in our debate we would
very much like to encourage your
participation where Marshall McLuhan in
this audience II will however smile
because we would request a view so that
this whole enterprise if I might use
that word is memorialized on tape that
you excuse those around you and pop up
and go to the microphone to ask
questions as you will and if we could
take over the next minute or so and give
that to people who know that they would
indeed like to ask some questions
would you please then wind your way to
the mic and form some kind of a Oh
haphazard line behind it and we will
begin the questioning process shortly
choose me yes we are will be going
straight into it
my charge if I might make one to the
questioners is that they make their
questions brief that they indeed be
questions and that they of course allow
the participants in adequate time to
respond after each brief question the
side or the person that it is directed
to will have an opportunity of course to
respond at which time after which I will
turn to the other participants and ask
them if they would like to comment on
the question as well with your
assistance will be able to have as many
questions as you are motivated to ask
and will be able to move the program
along crisply with the first gentlemen
like to ask a question yes one for each
side if I may for the capitalists I'm
curious to know why
in modern society you view physical
force as the exclusive or even the most
insidious form of coercion in a society
in which you may build a home and find a
toxic waste dump built next to it if
there's no such thing as zoning laws do
you think that you can legitimately
restrict your analysis to physical force
and which side is most guilty of its
imposition for the socialist side one
question at a time please thank you
I'd like to answer your real question
which is the first part your example
does not illustrate if there is a toxic
waste dump
if someone dumps toxic waste next to
your home that is physical force that is
the infusion of deadly chemicals into
your property and perhaps into your body
and if you can go into court and prove
that you can have the
government in a capitalist society make
him compensate for you make him remove
it and make him compensate you for any
damage what I think you want to contrast
it with is so-called economic power why
do I consider physical force the only
form of coercion versus economic power
we're a big business General Motors
supposedly can make you buy their cars
IBM can make you buy an IBM computer I
have to leave it to the Socialists in
the audience or on the stage to give
better more convincing examples because
I can't hold it in my mind the reason I
make such a distinction while
advertising supposed to be brainwashing
is there's another example of economic
power the reason why I make a
distinction is that physical force is
the only thing that can cause you to
that can cause your reason to be
inoperative it nullifies your reason
remember my whole case was life as an
ultimate value reason is the major means
of achieving it and therefore no force
because the force is the anti mind if
somebody comes up you have a fantastic
commercial to try and get you to buy
some product that is not anywhere in the
same universe from someone coming up
pointing a gun at your head and saying
give me your wallet one leaves your mind
free to function and it's up to you to
judge the validity of the computer the
advertisement or whatever the other
deprives you of the ability to act on
your thinking and that is the the very
nature of coercion I mean that's the
meaning of coercion making you act
against your will well your will is the
ability to act according to your minds
decision so that's why there's a
life-and-death difference between force
and any other kind of social influence I
have to give one other example it's
considered force in some quarters if
you're not given help when you need it
well that is completely wrong if a woman
that I want to sleep with won't sleep
with me that is not force if I break my
leg through my own
carelessness or through lightning
striking it and someone else won't heal
it
that is not imposing force upon me force
means force it means physical contact
with another's person or property
against his will without his consent and
that's the only thing that can negate a
mind and therefore destroy a life thank
you mr. benswanger
socialist response I would like to at
least initially limit the questioners to
one question of peace you're welcome to
move to the end of the line and get
ready to ask your next question thank
you so much
your single question sir yes I'd like to
pick up on a claim that mr. if I can
call him mr. Redpath said that the
socialists were just stating values and
didn't get into their ethics I'd like to
advance a thesis and have both sides
comment on this and that is that there
is a very basic metaphysical difference
between the Objectivists and the
Socialists the Socialists seem to be
saying that a socialist system is a
historical inevitability that talk about
morality is superfluous the Socialists
are just pointing out a trend that must
lead to socialism the Objectivists are
claiming that man is historically
autonomous there's no historical context
that necessitates the evolution towards
any political system social ethics are
needed to help us decide which political
and economic system we should adopt my
thesis then is that there is a basic
metaphysical difference between the
Socialists and capitalists in this
debate a much more cleverly asked double
question with the Socialists like to
respond first
well is this mic on I suppose the the
different let me put the difference in
another way our our capitalist opponents
or I can call them that I think that
don't have a conception of history upon
which they base individual possibilities
and values whereas what I would say of
our view is that it is framed in terms
of what is historically possible and the
ideals that socialists believe in are
themselves ideals that have arisen
through various historical struggles so
that I think that's the difference I
think it's a difference between if I may
put it a kind of a timeless metaphysics
of man and a historical philosophy thank
you hello I think that in some respects
you're right I don't know that all
socialists take the deterministic view
that Marx took but I think you have hit
on a point that the Socialists certainly
the ones that our historical
determinists may not find it necessary
to make arguments for the pursuit of
different human values because their
view is that these things are innocents
historically conditioned whereas the
Objectivists are certainly advocating a
view of man which regards men's free
will is the crux to all of his moral
choices and regards man as in control of
his destiny at every moment in history
so in that sense we don't have I was
just referred to as a historical
perspective if you like human beings for
human beings a question is what is the
nature of a human being
how does a human being live what does he
require what are the needs of human life
and our argument is that this has been
true of human beings through history and
it's not a story
the relative thing that men have
required freedom all through history and
the fact that they have had freedom so
infrequently through history is a sad
commentary on human history up until
this time but it does not prove the
historical the determined set of values
that some socialist determines
determinists believe is the case thank
you next question please
let me first of all say that I think
that the most promising thing we've
heard tonight for the future of our
social system is that mr. Binswanger has
agreed not to have children my question
to you mr. Binswanger my question to you
tonight the question tonight is one of
moral justification I'd like to ask you
how you can morally justify and you
attempted to a system which admits to to
the justification of inequality economic
inequality where the accumulation of
wealth the ownership of property does
not necessarily as you said need to be
equal perhaps if all things were equal
to start with if everyone was starting
out on the same starting line the the
certain mr. benswanger has informed me
that he objects to the ad hominem common
and will not be answering your question
and I would hope
[Applause]
[Music]
and I would hope that we could keep the
level of the debate not only clever but
on the point of the issues involved next
question please listen to the no sir
you've asked your question thank you I'm
going asking those a hurry and John the
capitalist system I think is I believe
the anglo-saxon society mostly time
thinking exploitation historically with
tell us comparing with the theory of the
Greek or Roman society I'm talking about
this modern capitalism where is this
monopolize exploit not only all your
polos this practice practice too much
exploitation to people however the
capitalism is is almost 10% up in class
so I like to ask you a question please
the capitalist is immoral because Jesus
was king of the earth also was
sympathize with the socialism true on
earth
I the question is true or not that Jesus
was a socialist I would I would think
you have a good case to make the case
that we are making for capitalism is a
case for a social system as I said in my
remarks that hasn't yet existed all that
you hear about the alleged evils of
capitalism with regards to exploitation
in regards to monopolies and all of this
is quite frankly a complete
misrepresentation of what capitalism is
it is not relate to what we are talking
about at all but I will say in regards
to you know bringing in Jesus that the
fact of the matter is that the case we
are making is a radical attack on the
ethics of judeo-christianity we are
rejecting the cross we are rejecting
sacrifice we are in rejecting state and
forced sacrifice we are standing up for
a man's mind for reason for this earth
and for freedom so you're right Jesus
and we are on opposite sides
a rejoinder yes those is my microphone
life yeah yeah there's a trite school of
thought that does try and maintain that
you can derive socialism from
Christianity and I hope I said enough to
make play that I think that's that's
nonsense
Christianity is historically the
ideology of feudalism and of slavery and
with this it's been very strongly
compatible and I think remains as to
whether Jesus was or was not I don't
know because I have no view of whether
he existed or said any of the things
that are attributed to him some of the
more popular remarks attributed to Jesus
I would say uncontroversial remarks
tending towards a view of the
brotherhood of man are of course
pre-christian wholly admirable points
about the interdependence of the human
race and the need the need to help
others for one's own sake
these are uncontroversial pre-christian
and obviously easily similar to
socialist morality thank you next
question there are around 40 countries
in the world that call themselves
socialists today including and some of
those who have been perpetuated the most
appalling deeds of violence and against
and human beings in our century and the
the amount of violence seems be an
adverse proportion the end non
socialists and elements mixed into the
particular society even if then the
argument socialists are true should we
risk a system that can obviously go so
easily off the rails off the rails
metaphor
it's just a just to show how complicated
things are here let me first make a
remark about this last controversy which
is that I have to dissent from my
comrade Hitchens view of Christianity
and religion even though I'm on the
Judeo rather than the Christian side of
the controversy you have to remember
Christianity's also the the the religion
of the early Puritans I mean there's a
lot of you can make it you can make a
case for socialism coming out of a
certain strain of Christianity though to
equate one with the other would be silly
and trite now socialist societies today
both our sides are in kind of a peculiar
position which is whenever we accuse the
capitalist of doing something terrible
they just say well we're not talking
about that we're talking about our
capitalism and we're in the same problem
here and let me try to make that point
though analytically rather than
normatively or morally Hegel had it as a
concept of the cunning of reason you
know that idea it's a the idea that what
people intend to do that history isn't
the sum of individuals intentions and
that you cannot so that you cannot you
cannot understand a society necessarily
by by its name the fact that there's so
many societies call themselves socialism
doesn't mean that the that the
historical movement that began in the
19th century has come to fruition in the
20th century instead we have a kind of
example of the of the cunning of reason
where a name has been appropriated just
as the Nazis appropriated the name
socialism it was at the time the name of
a popular philosophy in a popular
politics you have to remember things
were not as they are today an American
to be called a socialist in the Europe
was something desirable it was a way of
winning working-class support so the
Nazis called themselves in that
national-socialist there are social
democratic parties around the world that
have very little income and I think in
South America there's several that are
that are you can like on almost national
capitalist in nature so a terminology
doesn't necessarily make a doesn't
necessarily make history and that you
have to explain the term and understand
how it came to be rejoinder just a quick
comment that while you're I gather your
question is what are the socials have to
say about the fact that approximations
of their ideas seem to have resulted in
so much destruction in this 20th century
and have so many figure nodes built in
and the way to achieving whatever yeah
and their answer is well their ideals
have been misappropriated in the 20th
century well I can that may or may not
be the case depending on what particular
version of socialism one is putting
forward but the fact of the matter is
that Karl Marx for example is not
unrelated to what has happened in the
20th century Hegel is not unrelated to
what has have his a major influence on
the Nazis and I must say that even
though I would never I am not familiar
with the writings of my opponents but
they haven't said anything to me to
suggest that they personally endorsed
the bloodshed of the 20th century but I
will say this the print some of the
principles that they share are shared by
the two tyrants of the 20th century that
have caused that bloodshed they are
status socialism of any kind is a
statist philosophy and what has caused
the bloodshed in the 20th century is
different versions of statism so rather
than have to say well we're a different
version of this Creed which has in fact
caused so much destruction at least we
can sit here and say we reject the whole
Creed all together thank you
mr. chairman mr. chairman if I could
crave your indulgence if I was so loud
to speak at this point I think I could I
could economize on later questions
tending to the same point and clear up
an earlier misrepresentation of our
position all at once may I try yes you
mail it is the single most vulgar
misrepresentation of Marxism to say that
it's determinist the person who says
that of it that convicts himself at once
of not never having opened a book by
Marx or by Marxists most it was before
its time and remains the most
determinedly and avidly anti determinist
mode of thought in philosophy most
famously and you'll see why I'm
stressing this in a second Marx began
his his most famous account of history
and revolution the eighteenth Brumaire
of Louie Napoleon by saying men make
history but they do not make it under
circumstances as their own choosing they
make it but under circumstances directly
transmitted and engaged from the past
the traditions of all the dead
generation see them famously added way
like a nightmare on the brain of the
living that's not determinism
self-evidently not determinism no let me
say why I think this bears on the
question of violence men make history
but they can't choose when and how
they're going to make it if it was up to
me and I think I would carry john judas
with me here the the russian revolution
would have happened in 1905 when there
was a large democratic revolution led by
socialists that was put down by the tsar
and which with tremendous bloodshed in
repression and which paved the way for a
ghastly imperialist war in which
millions of russians were killed under
the leadership of the system of
hereditary god-given monarchy which was
the system with which capitalism in
russia was at that time coexisting now
it is not therefore by the socialist
choice that revolution took place in
russia at the close of that gigantic war
and bloodletting and gigantic tearing a
part of the fabric of russian society to
the point where cannibalism had
reemerged in the countryside an
emergence in my submission that is not
unrelated to the later course of events
in the soviet union it's quite simply on
historical to say that well revolutions
devour their children you said you then
surrender the need to analyze
history and you can simply look at
history as the working out of that
proposition
very good means of economizing on
thought and one that I think should be
repudiated very thoughtful Objectivist
thank you a brief rejoinder and then
we're going to return to the questioning
all right let's look at this in
principle let's not try and say well
maybe because it was raining in South
Yemen when they took over it was a bad
time for them to take over and that's
why socialism failed and maybe because
Afghanistan went this way and because
the Cuba's dependent on one crop and
because you know there's always an
explanation ad hoc as to why every
single socialist nation that takes
socialism seriously ends up with
concentration camps and mass slaughter
let's look at it in principle in
principle what else can you expect if
the government owns all the property in
the country if there is no right to
private property
if you cannot own your own printing
press for example from which you can
criticize the government if the state
owns all the printing presses all the
radios if the means of making a living
is in the hands of one group which
maintains it by force the government so
that he who does not work shall not eat
becomes a government edict what else can
you expect if you make it a crime to
train on the black market in other words
to engage in capitalist acts yet people
have to engage in these black market
activities in order to feed themselves
what else can you expect but more and
more black market and more and more
repression to keep it down there's no
escape from a system of any state as
kind leading to disaster if it gives all
that power to the government now the
capitalist system says the most
dangerous thing in the world is a
government
let's restrain it let's keep it down
let's give it only one function the
function of protecting your freedom from
criminals and foreign aggressors let's
not let it mess in any other area of
your of your life let's just have the
and the law-courts and let's not have it
be also your employer and the owner of
everything so in other words we believe
in very very drastically restricted
limited government now since
government's the culprit here doesn't
that point to the answer to your
question thank you next question yeah
since there is a need for brevity I'll
make my question as short as possible if
one does an historical analysis of the
situation as exists in the world at
present there's an increasing tendency
in the part of third world countries to
gravitate towards the socialist ideal
why have it maybe and I'd like both
sides of the fence to address the
question as to why this is so is it an
ineptness and a part of radicals and
intellectuals or is it clear analysis of
historical perspectives capitalist I'd
like to start yeah I've observed that
myself I of course would put a different
coloration on it than the other side I
think the more advanced and intellectual
countries have learned that socialism
just does not work so the only place
that socialism can be sold now is in
very backward countries that intersect
still following the fashions of the
1930s but it's you notice in Italy for
example they came to the brink of euro
communism and backed off in France they
had a socialist government and backed
away from it I don't think you can fool
the people anymore the way you could in
the 30s in an industrial civilised
society say by saying you know we want
socialism because we don't want to
promise you pie in the sky we want to
make you rich here on earth and
socialism is the way to make you rich
that was the original promise of
socialism money food shelter work but
you know a good job and rewarding income
now that's just you know been completely
disproved by quote historical analysis
by fact and the only place you can get
away with it now is with people who
aren't that well educated now I hope
that's not taken as an ad hominem that's
my hypothesis as to you know why it is
that is not possible to spread true
socialism in an advanced society
rejoinder
that reminds me of one of William
Buckley's comments in an interview in
1961 when somebody asked him why whether
he thought that what was at the time the
Belgian Congo they were fighting for
their independence whether they whether
they could ready for democracy and he
said well they'd be ready for democracy
when they stop eating each other then
not to be so much to be funny as to
signal my disagreement with a
perspective of mr. benswanger the my own
view is that the reason that the
third-world countries have that
socialism has been popular is that you
have to conceive of the world economy as
a gigantic division of labor in which
most of those countries economies have
been pretty much at the behest of the
core economies in the world the advanced
capitalist countries in which and in
which they've been structured in such a
way as to benefit those core economies
but not not to benefit themselves so you
have sort of single crop agriculture
primarily for export you have you you
have no internal market in those
countries and the the ruling elites that
go away to school and come back and get
it into their heads that in order to
change that around they have to have
some form of a command economy where
they take control of their own society
and their economy now when they've done
that and when they've experimented with
a while sometimes they found that they
do need elements of a market and then
foreign capital is attractive but that's
the reason that that element of the
socialist idea appeals in those
countries thank you
next another questioner please ask a
question thank you my question is
directed to mr. Hitchens in reference to
the comments he made the last part of
the formal debate
you gave the argument that because
capitalism in practice requires
expropriation and robbery that there are
so few developed capitalist States and
gave the example of the alleged British
expropriation of India this leads me to
wonder from what
of India did the British expropriate the
steam engine and the many intellectual
developments which sparked the
Industrial Revolution in that country
if material goods were the Fundamental
prime cause of the Industrial Revolution
why didn't the Indians have their own
Industrial Revolution centuries before
the British came along in summary I
asked didn't the Industrial Revolution
require reason and intellect as its
prime cause rather than expropriation
would that the question was as clever as
it sounds have you served or was anyone
else here read Edmund Burke's speech on
the impeachment of Warren Hastings you
might care to turn it up it's a it's a
kind of a classic conservative text in
there you will find laid out in some
detail the description of the enormous
transfer of wealth from India to the
islands in the North Sea known as Great
Britain and Northern Ireland today but
was in fact so alarmed by this process
it wasn't out of compassion for India
that he mentioned it he was alarmed that
the process was was in fact enriching a
whole new class that would corrupt
Parliament in Britain and not without
reason and that's why Hastings had to be
impeached that is how some of the
capital that led to the Industrial
Revolution was accumulated that's what I
said
now it's also true that India got the
steam engine as a result probably rather
earlier than it would have otherwise
which is why Marx said as I said that
the British were probably justified in
putting down the Indian mutiny of 1857
because that mutiny was not a struggle
for independence it was an attempt to
restore the Mogul Imperial authorities
who were a relatively less advanced mode
of production
now isn't that clear if I didn't make it
clear before let me take the opportunity
to make it clear now that is the
complement Marxism pays to the origins
of capitalism I haven't yet though had
an answer to my question about why
capitalism did not emerge in such very
large and theoretically prosperous and
productive areas of the club and I do
think that it is a question that
deserves an answer from the capitalist
side rejoinder
I'm having somewhat of trouble hearing
every word descending in the sound
system the acoustics we have some
trouble hearing you
over here but I heard a couple of things
that I will respond to colonialism is
the best thing that ever happened to the
colonies we view the colonialization of
India and the rest of the world by
England
primarily and then later by other
countries including ourselves as the
extending of wealth and civilization to
backward reason regions all the
interactions in essence I mean I can't
say that you know every single one of
them but the essence the thrust of those
interactions was free trade voluntary
employment for people who were otherwise
start as one other aside concrete from
this the Arabs have no right to that oil
the same principle oil under the feet of
people who don't know what property is
who don't have a civilized society who
are nomads or dictatorships is not the
property of their little king it is the
property of any body who comes in and
produces it and it was the American and
Western oil companies that produce that
oil even they even went made contracts
with those little petty dictators even
though you know they morally had no
claim to that oil and the same principle
goes to any other natural resources
natural resources belong to those people
who make use of them and there was the
civilized countries that took things
that were just junk and garbage to the
rest of the world and paid them for them
the transfer of wealth was both ways and
much more to the benefit of the backward
people as sure common sense would tell
you than it was to England India needed
England a thousand times more than the
other way around now the challenge which
I hadn't actually hadn't heard before
was why didn't capitalism develop in
large areas of the world like India
where it didn't develop because we
believe that capitalism does not develop
out of historical necessity but out of
people's ideas capitalism reached its
apex in the United States and 1776
because the ideas of the people were
those of John Locke every one of the
founding fathers read john locke they
read Aristotle they read Cicero this is
known fact the language of John Locke's
Second Treatise of government is in the
independence of the Declaration of
Independence the political philosophy of
England at that time is what caused
capitalism to exist here now needless to
say the opposite political philosophy is
in place and in areas like India they
are mystics they don't believe in reason
they don't believe in nature they don't
believe in natural rights so the answer
is where there is a pro-capitalist
philosophy their capitalism will
flourish where there isn't it won't
thank you next question I'd like to ask
this question of mr. Hitchens and it's a
question that seems to be purely
practical but really it does have a
theoretical underpinning as well it
implies a theoretical question and that
is I have a question about how you would
see how we ought to best make the
transition to socialism and in
particular what I'm worried and what I'm
wondering about is how far you take what
you took as your first principle of
socialism and that was the divisions of
class sex and race ought to be ignored
in the establishment of it and what I'm
wondering in particular is how would you
look upon for example affirmative action
quotas and hiring and the reason I ask
that question is it seems to me that
socialist ideology Marxist ideology has
a tendency and perhaps this is not fair
to accuse anyone on the stage of this
but other theorists to view man as an
economic entity as filling the way to
look at mandatory under stand his place
in society is to look at the way he
interacts with other people on a
material basis and and so this this is
my question how would you look at that
particular way of establishing social
justice
yes I think I think it's a it's
certainly a two-part maybe a tripartite
question on the on the matter of
transition that you asked me to deal
with an enormous subject I would say
this sketchily announcer to be forgiving
there are it is it is the stated
position of many conservatives
ideologues in Western capitalist Europe
that the the economies of Western Europe
have in a sort of vegetable evolution
already
come social-democratic and though i
don't think that claim is wholly true
there is a great deal of truth in it
there are countries are the one most
often cited cell cited for convenience
is Sweden where though the vast majority
of the economy remains in private hands
and in fact in the hands of the same
families as controlled Swedish
capitalism in the 19th century same
names rather like German capitalism
before and after Nazism and during of
course the there is not more than a
welfarist conception of society in
Sweden a very nearly a social democratic
coexistence so that's one case where in
it one might almost call it an evolution
in other cases my theory is the ones
I've cited the Soviet Union and I would
add these two these China and Cuba where
capitalism simply broke down and there
was no force or agency ready to take
over the running of the countries but
the communist and socialist movements
but capitalism abandoned and evacuated
and failed in those countries leaving no
alternative that you could say that was
a revolution or you could simply say it
was a collapse calling a transition
would certainly be weak I have a feeling
I'll be taken up on some of this but
that's my broad-brush transition
statement on the apparent paradox in
what I say about over looking or
transcending differences among the
broader family of the human race my own
view is that that is compatible with
making a stand for affirmative action
because it is a willed compensation for
past wrongs and one has to be able to
identify and compensate a given group
that isn't to discriminate in the
pejorative sense actually it is the
racialist who cannot discriminate I've
never understood by race lists are
accused of discrimination it's the one
Faculty of which they're not capable
they think that all members of a certain
race have the same characteristics and
don't share the ability to discriminate
among them as humans as to the economic
man no look we don't believe that you
are what you eat it can be shown that
you you aren't what you don't eat and if
and if you don't you are not
the corollary wouldn't and and pray
there's a lot too much of that a lot of
it in the capitalist world but no we
realized that there are other needs many
of them non-material let me suggest an
example to you the case of the person
who gives blood and does so voluntarily
and without a reward there's no
sacrifice involved in that you don't
lose a pint of blood by giving one but
you do help another person and you don't
have to posit altruism you have
fulfilled your own need to help and be
of service without giving up anything
and without a cash transaction and
you've increased the general welfare I
regard that is as a socialist attitude
to one's fellow creatures and perfectly
unsentimental thank you a briefly
joinder I agree with much of what you
said in the middle that racism is the
failure to discriminate I think that
racism is a form of collectivism which
says that the collective that counts is
a racial one as opposed to Marx for
instance who thinks that collective that
counts is an economic one but we reject
all those and say that collectives don't
exist
individuals exist and they are to be
judged on the basis of their own
attributes their own choices and their
own actions so I would maintain that
only individualism is an antidote to
racism as in in relation to the giving
blood example well sure there are I
don't personally find the giving blood
to be that easy I tend to faint but if
you take an action where the cost to the
individual is so minimal that he in fact
won't miss it and someone else is
benefited by it fine there's no argument
against that whatsoever it's very nice
lot of things in human life for that way
like when you smile and say hello to
somebody or a good morning how are you
doesn't cost you anything expresses
benevolence and respect for human life
but that has nothing to do with the
question of people are dying right now
in hospitals in many parts of world
including
nine states where certain people could
save them but it would require them
giving a lot of their blood
maybe one person if we took these got a
rare blood type here's the question I
posed one person has the Rh negative
Type O or something if we took all his
blood we could save five other people's
lives now that's not far-fetched is that
do you have the right to take all his
blood do you have the right to take one
drop of his blood
if he doesn't consent capitalism says no
so remember when you say well capital
have repeatedly referred the theory
capitalism historically didn't work out
there was nothing to replace it
capitalism came gave rise to problems as
if capitalism were some independent
entity remember when we're talking about
capitalism we're talking about freedom
we're talking about free trade we're
talking about non interference so what
they're really saying is well we tried
leaving people free but it just didn't
work out so we had to come in with a
different system thank you thank you in
deference to the line of questioners and
the late hour and at least the heat on
this stage if the subsequent questioners
could please state their question very
briefly and if the respondents to the
questions could as Edwin Newman might
ask on Meet the Press please give the
briefest of answers something around the
category of one minute each we could
then work our way through many of the
questioners who are still in line next
question please doctor doctor doctor you
gave a brief response regarding how the
two each according to his need related
to the family I was not really as
satisfied with your answer I am and what
I have read of objective is rice nicely
to your question sir my question is what
does objectivism have to offer to
children to people who do not have a
fighting chance as adults what does it
have to offer to quadriplegics to people
who are weak and cannot help themselves
thanks
what to socialism have to offer to those
who are able to help themselves and how
do the quadriplegic and the weak hope to
survive if the producers are throttled
so that they can't produce there's
really two questions there one is the
issue of parents and children and from
each according to his ability and so
forth the parent-child relation is not
the relationship of adult citizens to
each other which politics is primarily
concerned with certainly a parent owes
the care to its child and the child owes
gratitude for that care if it's if it's
provided properly but the point is that
you are not a child and the government
should not treat you as a child there is
such a thing as reaching the age of
reason but under some forms of
government that age is never reached in
other words they never believe that you
reach adulthood and have rights
it is not altruism but love that the
parent-child relationship exhibits it is
not of to each according to his need so
you want me to cut out okay thank you
response place wasn't really to us I
think personally wonderful next question
please I have a question for mr.
Hitchens you've spoken on the subject
but I'm still not sure of your opinion
on the most basic level of this debate
it seems to me has addressed the
question do the ends justify the means
in your opinion do they I don't find it
possible to say no to that question I
think there's more absurdity and more
contradiction and less interest in the
study of history revealed in someone who
simply says no to that and then there is
to someone who says yes but someone who
says yes clearly invites about further
questions which you haven't asked I
I don't mean to be either evasive
elusive next question please thank you
very briefly vague I could say yes the
ends justify the means if the ends are
rational then the means will be rational
to it it's a rather vague question which
I think is when mr. Hitchens was saying
next question thank you Thanks both
sides seemed to address themselves to
the rights and responsibilities of
humans to each other but there's very
little said about the rights and
responsibilities of humans to the
environment they live in and I think the
poor record of both 18th century rather
19th century capitalism and modern
socialism as far as the environment
demonstrates that neither side has very
little to offer in that area and I'm
wondering what both sides feel that
their policies have to offer to those of
us who are who are concerned about the
environment ok modern capitalism has
more to offer than 19th century
capitalism and some extent more than
than modern socialism so I would say as
I the I tried to lay out in that my
eight minutes that some modern socialism
as I was trying to describe it will will
itself evolve and emerge out of modern
capitalism and therefore will
incorporate such of the environmental
movement today as we see so I you know I
I accept your point response if if in
essence is the survival human survival
the living of human life requires to go
out into the world and produce the
values for the sustenance of life in a
certain sense in essence life involves
attacking the environment that's what
it's that's what we're doing so that
capitalism in essence is a system which
on Alisha's people's energies to go out
and try to make what they can from the
world the values of human life requires
the record of productive activities such
as you were mentioning earlier the
dumping poisonous wastes next door to
you etcetera examples of pollution
that actually do attack individuals
right to their own life their own health
etc are examples of the fact that the
principle of human rights has not been
fully understood it was not even fully
understood in 1776 and it has not been
consistently applied in legal philosophy
at to this day so there are a lot of
problems to be dealt with but what we
first need in order to deal with those
problems is an understanding of what the
principle commands rights means thank
you my friend are you here with your
second question yes all right I would
like all right the the all right the
gentlemen we're going to go for two more
questions
my deepest apologies to those others in
line my fear is there would be people in
line for a very long time and in an
effort to bring the program in at
approximately two hours unless either of
the two gentlemen would like to defer
they'll be the last two questioners yes
my question for the socialists do you in
your opinion was Stalin more an
aberration or a product of socialist
history that preceded him it would be
true to say that you couldn't have had
Stalin without Lenin those who make that
accusation are I would say you know in
an almost banal and self-evident sense
correct it is also true that for the
consolidation of his power
Stalin found it necessary to physically
exterminate and liquidate what had been
Lenin's Bolshevik Party thus I think
there's no one-sided answer to that
question I think that with the exception
of the People's Republic of China which
is now about it seems on its own
interpretation of the capitalist Road
there is no other socialist community
where the name of Joseph Stalin is
regarded with anything but execration
whether or not this is an irony I leave
it to you to decide
thank you
final question my question is for the
capitalist what kind of political system
would you would get away with welfare
since he would take the altruism of the
recipients I mean the recipients would
have to vote against cutting their own
benefits right so how would you change
the Constitution in what way could you
sir clarify the question well it seems
to me that the if the new system would
have to get away with some civil
liberties in order such so that the
recipients of well given that the
population now votes half-and-half
between getting away with the welfare or
not then the deciding factor is
obviously the people that actually have
welfare now what kind of constitutional
amendments would you suggest such that
the welfare recipients would not have
the civil liberty of choosing for this
vote or no vote okay I think the
assumption of your question is that you
could not get rid of the welfare system
unless you took the vote away from those
who are its beneficiaries I don't agree
with that I don't think that people vote
their pocketbook I think that if you
convince people that they're better off
in a different system they'll vote for
it and as a matter of actual fact
welfare recipients are not a happy lot
and as a matter of actual fact they
would be far better off under a
capitalist society and if we could
convince a majority of the electorate
including both welfare recipients and
non welfare recipients of that simple
point then welfarism will fade away and
it I don't believe that economic
interest determine ideology the other
way around
this man will have to be altruistic too
to give away their benefits no no more
selfishness in India I'm saying I'm
saying it is not in your self-interest
to be a welfare recipient and it's
pretty obvious all you have to do is
just look at them in the main there are
pretty mangy lot and if you had a child
would you tell it and it suppose it
could live in one of two societies in
one society half the people on welfare
and it could qualify for welfare the
other society no one can qualify for
welfare but the standard of living is
ten times that of the other of the
welfare society and growing daily which
one would you tell your child to enter
so we believe that self-interest is the
interest of life and that life is not
life as a passive vegetable but the life
of productive activity so we don't think
the mere fact that someone writes you a
check means that that's to your
self-interest thank you so much
[Applause]
in this final section of the debate each
side will have four minutes to summarize
its ideas however it so chooses and
however it wants to divide up that time
mr. judas and mr. Hitchens will begin
this process and they will both speak
for a combined total of four minutes
[Music]
well I'm still trying to figure out what
the difference between us is that is
precisely and I think I keep coming back
to this point about metaphysics versus a
historical view of human beings and I
think that that what I find in the in
the philosophy that I've heard tonight
is what what I'd call a kind of
reification of capitalist man where the
traits that we associate with early
capitalism of exchange self-interested
exchange pursuit of profit are
understood in such a way as to encompass
all of human nature itself so that you
get a kind of philosophy extolling
selfishness but I think that that's such
an understanding both slights human
nature and tramples upon language as it
can Stan used to say language takes a
holiday when you talk that way and what
we mean ordinarily by such terms as
selfishness and altruism and taking care
of people and loving each other and
being worried about about the others
besides ourselves become lost
point number two I don't think that the
that the the objective is if I could
call you that I have much to offer
society today it is hard for me to find
even grounds for debate between you
since your proposals as far as I can see
would in effect
take us if they were successful take us
back to the early 19th century and I
said don't simply don't think it's
possible I think that I think that your
philosophy is hopelessly utopian I think
I'll just close by insisting on a point
we've both made in different ways we
regard capitalism as a system not as an
idea and therefore something that is a
proper study of analysis of history and
of economics as well as of that of
political competing ideology that is I
think that is the insight that the
Objectivists deny themselves and end up
with the I would have thought
superfluous injunction to humans
to be self-interested an injunction that
does not seem as one looks around to be
very much needed an idea that doesn't
appear to require an enormous amount of
reinforcement though it might something
require more justification that it's had
this evening capitalism as a system has
coexisted with and in on occasion
sponsored feudalism monarchy fascism
slavery apartheid and under development
it has also been the great engine of
progress development and innovation in a
certain few Heartland countries this
means that it must be a system studied
as a system and not as an idea its
claims to be the sponsor of freedom are
purely contingent it's good propaganda
but it's not very good political science
in the same way those of us who take and
hold to the socialist view in this
century a perfectly well aware of the
appalling crimes and failures as well as
of the defeats that our movement is
associated with my final submission I
think would be that no one bothers to
counterfeit a bad currency and that the
claim of so many people who don't
deserve it to the socialist title gives
one hope for a
heightened application of the idea in
the non capitalist future
[Applause]
I just want to briefly remark on the the
level we're getting down to is now a
metaphysical epistemological which is
very good it's a good sign the earlier
statement now reiterated by mr. Hitchens
that he's not a determinist seems to fly
in the face of what he just said which I
take as strict determinism it's it does
not cease to be determinism if you say
man makes history and then add to it of
course what he makes of history he had
to make of history determinism is
precisely that view that human actions
certainly have effects but determinism
claims that the causes are necessary so
that in a certain situation only one
result is possible if you're here
tonight determinism says you had to be
we assert free will we start that you
have particularly the free will to use
your mind to think for yourself or not
and that that's why we reject the entire
methodology of the socialist side in
this debate the idea of historical
analysis that capitalism is not in that
an idea and so forth it's basically an
issue of free will versus determinism my
concluding remarks I'd like to address
two things said by mr. Judas the first
was that objectivism has much to offer
society today it's hopelessly utopian
literal meaning of utopian means no
place is not of this reality well in in
fact we have been arguing that as the
socialist ideas that are not of this
reality we are trying to argue that
capitalism is a social system that
requires required by the actual real
nature of man and hardly hopelessly
utopian it is in fact of tremendously
practical importance that men come to
understand their social requirements I
would also like to say that I hope
objectivism has a lot to offer society
today because in the absence of that I
have a very bleak view of what
you will be I also want to address the
question of still trying to figure out
what is the difference between us well
I'll tell you what the difference is
between us
in essence the difference between us is
the difference between the Enlightenment
and the 19th century German Romanticism
ideas matter ideas determine the course
of human affairs this country is the
product of a certain set of ideas it is
the product of the 18th century
enlightenment ideas I love this country
I'm not from this country I'm a Canadian
but I love this country and I love the
values that it stands for
I love the Statue of Liberty and the
Declaration of Rights and Disneyland and
the Constitution and everything that's
unique about America which is actually
the product of the best attempt so far
to adopt a philosophical outlook which
the Enlightenment stands for the
philosophy of Aristotle of Locke of
Cicero the philosophy of man's natural
rights and that's where we stand where
they stand is with the philosophy of
Rousseau Kant Hegel Marx the British
Fabian socialists it's a completely
different tradition it's a European
tradition of thought now the fact the
matter is these two philosophical
traditions are at opposite ends to each
other their direct odds with each other
and one of these systems at least is
false so I'd like to conclude by saying
that the benefit to man of discovering
true ideas and following them is legion
and this country and its greatness is an
example of what can happen if you just
approximately discover some true ideas
but the damage and destruction to man of
discovering false ideas is also legion
and you have two sets of ideas up before
you tonight and it's now up to you to
decide which set of ideas deserve your
allegiance thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
I'm certain I'm certain your applause or
on behalf of all the participants the
participants and and most particularly
the Objectivist club would like to thank
you for your forbearance and your
patience and your enthusiasm this
evening I think a fair plate of
intellectual nourishment has been served
up to complement that plate and perhaps
soothe your thirsts if you would please
join us in room 501 of the Marvin Center
we would look forward to engaging you in
discussion thank you so much
[Applause]
well Jeff will check I must have a peep
you wouldn't if I where's mom I'll be
back in two seconds
like
I guess we'll see you out
[Music]
[Music]
but she got this you know